as a small aside maybe you can guide me
through it i don't know if you're paying
attention
but there was some chaos
around tele and the bitcoin community i
wasn't
quite paying attention but from my
outsider's perspective i thought
uh seemed to lab was a supporter of
bitcoin
and then a lot of people were very upset
about something i'm sorry if i don't
know the details but
can you can you pull out some profound
philosophical
ideas from the disagreement of the chaos
i admittedly
don't know too much about it either i
i've a big fan of his writing
um he's always
been a little different in person like i
actually he signed one of my books i met
him in person he's just
he's got a very abrasive personality
he's kind of known for it it's not
i don't think i'm passing any judgment
here he sort of embraces it
yeah but he had written um the forward
to a really important book in bitcoin
called the bitcoin standard
for safety in a moose and then i think
they had a little
twitter beef because safety was is very
much against
covet mask and state intervention
or celebs on the other side of the fence
right and so
and then after that beef taleb came out
against bitcoiners saying oh bitcoins
are crazy and wrong
i think the great mass debate of the
2020 will probably be the thing that
ultimately leads to world war three
i've been very surprised how tense
how much like division yeah this one
little
arguably silly thing has led to
i think a lot of people sort of project
their like
it's almost like not wearing a mask is a
statement of sovereignty of freedom
of like saying [ __ ] you to the man the
government the centralized power
or the dishonesty or the
in the scientific community all those
kinds of things and then wearing a mask
is a sort of kind of signaling
of various kind of
social aspects i don't know i'm not
paying attention to it i actually tuned
out
i was part of a group of scientists that
were looking into like dumask's work
this very interesting question to me was
an interesting question
i sort of roll in to ask that very
interesting question
because i think it is an interesting
scientific question but then i quickly
realized that just as i was
doing this like scientific exploration
of this very interesting question
about viron particles like what kind of
things like
from a scientific perspective how do we
prevent the spread of a pandemic forget
covid independent
super deadly or not deadly like there's
tools there's testing there's masks
there's all these tools how well do they
work
and then i realized you know in april or
so
it became a tool of politics a tool of
philosophy
and that's when i sort of pulled out so
it's fascinating i i think it's a
it's a it's a canvas on which people
project their emotions and i guess
until i'm got caught up in that kind of
so there's nothing fundamental
i suppose to their disagreement not that
i'm aware of
but he is you know he's written some
about in his books the problem with
centralization
i mean a lot of his writing um addresses
that he actually
points to i think switzerland is the
best government in the world because
it's decentralized
um so there's that i don't think he has
any
i'm not not to speak for him but i don't
think he's
uh voiced any specific critiques on
bitcoin per se
could be wrong about that it's it's just
maybe his flavorful language and the way
he
likes to communicate and the other
theory is that maybe he's playing 4d
chess and having a twitter boating
accident
you know so i don't believe in bitcoin
i've sold all my bitcoin and
oh i see yeah what uh sorry the boating
accident in bitcoin is
this um i guess it's proverbial by this
point where
it's the way you lose your bitcoin so
someone comes after you and says hey
you know whether it's a government or an
individual's coming after you saying
give me all your bitcoin or
pay these taxes and bitcoin go oh i had
a boating accident and lost them all
lost them all so yeah
you